1986 passes
well we
we basically made the video we shot it
in
may of 1986 we john edited it he's
credited as director you know for good
reason because he
he's the one who took all that footage
um an hour and edited it and and really
it's a great piece of editing and he
so he's the one who's really the
architect in my opinion but i produced
it with him and it's all it's a joint
effort i mean we we definitely share
in the ownership of
heavy metal parking lot but um
it was
we started screening it in the fall of
1986 and and then
showed it around the washington area
maryland where we're from
but we would just at the time you didn't
have any opportunities to screen
video and very few opportunities to
project video
it was and film festivals did not take
video
so
you were really limited in what you
could do and we ended up um just giving
it out on video vhs tape to anybody who
wanted a copy i didn't show it on public
access because i didn't want my
my
work to know that this is what i was you
know
recording i mean i was proud of it but i
think because we wanted to be
documentary filmmakers as opposed to
public access users
that was our goal we were happy to just
try to
see if we could get some documentary
cred with it and also i didn't need to
let management know that i was making
this kind of
content so that was fine um
because it was pretty raw as you
know
and uh
we showed it i think at some art
galleries and some night clubs and some
record stores
and
we did get it at the kennedy center the
american film institute theater was
there
and they had video projections so we got
it screened a few times there but by
1990 several years later we pretty much
had shelved it we we just put it in
mothballs we were tired of making our
friends watch it and we just couldn't
see where we just it was fine we felt it
had run its course
um
because we just didn't we couldn't
license it we didn't have any way to
afford the music rights
and be as you know we borrowed
the music that got sorted out later much
later and it's now on dvd and uh was
also on on tv
um
as part of a
a show called parking lot which went on
the trio tv network and so we've had
some success with the this parking lot
franchise uh but uh
it didn't hap until like 1994-95
we didn't know it was getting any
interest outside of just our friends in
the washington dc area
but people had been taping it and
trading it in fact it got into los
angeles at a store called mondo video
gogo which was down on vermont avenue it
moved around melrose vermont it moved
around a good deal guy named colonel rob
ran the store with his brother and and
he
had this um
you know really cool
hip
cult video store and they loved it they
got a copy and and colonel rob and his
friends were just great
at promoting it for us unbeknownst to us
they were actually
taking you know make anybody who came in
and they were showing it to them because
you know it's and so they they were
renting a copy
and at some point sophia coppola had
rented it and showed it rather wanted to
use it on
um a video a tv show she was putting
together called
um high octane tv
she called john hyde she got his name
out of the phone book
and then called him up out of the blue
this was around 1994 and said look i i
like the video i'd like to show it in my
tv show and john's like what who who who
is this what what's going on he didn't
know it was so
literally out of the blue and this is of
course you know way before the internet
or finding anybody she
got john's name and phone number from
long distance information so
that was our first inkling that it was
being um
getting known getting recognition
especially out in the entertainment
business and the entertainment community
in hollywood and we called up mondo
video and talked to colonel rob and he
was great and he was really happy to
hear from us and we were you know became
fast friends and found out who had been
renting it and who was interested in it
and liked it
and then sophia coppola she the tv show
didn't happen unfortunately
but they were going to put it in there
if it did
get off the ground
but um
after that is when we decided hmm maybe
we should get it out and start showing
it again and then create a
bit of a uh
you know we see what we could else what
else we could do to further this brand
and that's when we came up with the
sequel neil diamond parking lot
and then later a few years later harry
potter parking lot and
and ultimately the tv series that we
were involved with which went on trio
we've had a lot of um
uh
good fortune
but it was all
unplanned and a total
surprise
so did you ever find out who it was that
sort of took this missing link and well
yeah we have a we definitely know a
friend of ours uh somebody named mike
heath who lives in san francisco is a
friend and he showed up at my job i used
to work for a discovery channel um in
the early days like from 1990 to 95
after the public access studio i worked
that closed i was
on staff at discovery in the early days
you know back before it became this you
know global powerhouse which it is now i
mean it was becoming that but i got to
watch this incredible you know rise of
this
this um cable
you know network
um
i
mike showed up my job one day and asked
for copies of a
heavy metal parking lot because he was
moving to california and uh he wanted to
take some video copies
to give to friends
and mike is we consider him johnny
appleseed of uh heavy metal parking lot
because
he took about i think just four vhs
tapes which i gave him and from there it
got to um
i think uh
it was a musician who
sadly passed away a fellow named bill
bartel who was uh went by the name pat
pat fear in a band called white flag i
mean i know a lot of this just because i
i know all this esoteric history about
it because we've kind of tracked it and
and can connect the dots
and bill
um got a copy from mike
because they were friends and bill gave
so people were copying it and giving it
to their friends multi-generation i mean
pre-viral video you know you were
copying tape to tape and so this in this
case the tape you know
bill had it mike gave it to bill bill
gave it to a fellow named mike who was a
roadie for nirvana
uh and then he took it on the road um
with
nirvana and then everybody who came on
the nirvana bus this is all
nobody i learned this later you know i'm
not privy to this
history at the time this is what i've
been told so
it's like you know the elders passing
down this history um i i've just kind of
heard this and you know i've kind of
been
verified
but
because i know people would go on the
bus and so i mean i i'm so grateful that
this happened but it was so unplanned
and so such a surprise that it was
getting into people's you know orbit
that i could never have dreamed of and
uh and that they liked it
and that when we finally started to go
public more with it and dust it off and
and then try to work on some more um
similar uh
documentaries that we were able to at
least have a springboard you know and
and people like colonel rob at mondo uh
you know he was still he would then show
other stuff we had and became just a you
know further was a patron
of what we were doing and helping to
distribute it
you know again pre-internet
you still had to rent it or or tape it
you know go vhs to vhs no dial up yet no
no dial up no video no no no aol no aol
no
way way way god video i mean the
internet i i guess email was happening
at the time
maybe mid 90s but in a primitive fashion
so
you